i'm talking about something that the
world thinks is a contradiction i don't
understand why anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee
in a meeting ever i think humility is
one of my greatest strengths i would
argue that nobody that consumes my
content sees humility i also believe
that 98 of the world doesn't even think
about what i just said and all these
things are the foundation of success
mr
gary vaynerchuk in the house how you
doing man
i'm doing well evan how are you
i am amazing uh you guys you guys know
this man he's got he's got sneakers
he's got he's got books
he's got merch we're almost wearing the
same thing i don't know it's pretty
close
and he's got wine i drank all of mine i
was trying to find the wine but we
finished this we got to order a second a
second round uh and he's got a new book
12 and a half dude i'm so excited
welcome board looking forward to
chopping this up
thank you brother i'm really happy to be
with you it's good to see you i hope
you're well
um and uh yeah i'm really excited about
this book i was telling drock and ragav
and some of my crew mei i was telling
her like this the other day i was like
this is the first book that feels like
crush it since crush it
and and what i mean by that is
i think we all thank you
uh i think we all know
when we
went further than our capacity
you know when you like hold your breath
10 more seconds than you really believed
you could underwater or
you just did an extra set in the weight
room or
you just you know you
emotionally parented better that day
than what your consistent high level is
i i feel as though
what's unique about this book for me
personally is i'm incredibly proud of
all my books
they've all done extremely well
uh the amount i mean every day i get a
dm or email about java jabra hook and
how it helps somebody
uh the last book crushing it was really
a continuation of the book that i
mentioned but i knew when i wrote crush
it that it was my first album
you know like when you have your first
album for a lot of artists the reason
they are one album players is you have
your whole life to write it you know i
had my whole life to write crush it and
i wrote it at a time where it was very
obvious to me that the world is changing
and people can
make money
by doing what you like
what i wrote and crush it that was
became the biggest truth in our society
and i'm very proud of that
this book
feels the same
because much like when i wrote crush it
and if you go read the early amazon
reviews people are like yeah yeah you're
gonna make money being on youtube like a
real like it's really funny to read and
look back because it is 12 years ago and
the world was different in 2009
i think what's really interesting about
this is
this is a book that was written and
people going to read and be like
i don't think the things that i believe
make somebody an alpha business person
and are the competitive advantages
are accepted
in our society today i'll give an
example
i don't understand why anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee
in a meeting ever i will never i do not
believe that there is ever a time
to completely
make somebody feel lesser than in a
meeting aggressively amongst others
for any reason whatsoever i also believe
that 98 of the world doesn't even think
about what i just said
or necessarily agree with it because
it's been accepted in business
and i
don't think it should be and not because
i'm foofy
and i'm like
it's because i actually think it's
detrimental to the actual success of the
business what's interesting about what
i'm starting to understand about myself
is
i have a lot of points of view
that
may seem like a non-entrepreneur and
like a non-exit right it sounds more
like an ideology or or somebody who's
never been in business like has this
like dream that it could be like this
and in return i'm in it
i'm incredibly successful in it
i have a lot of people that i've
observed who are incredibly successful
in it
that
subconsciously and consciously believe
that it doesn't that kindness and good
behavior and all these things are the
foundation of success and i don't think
that's something we're talking about and
i'm
at a place in my career where i have a
big enough platform i have enough gray
hairs now
where i have clarity on this and i
wanted to write this book about traits
and i called it 12 and a half because
one of the biggest ones
kind candor
is something that i've struggled with
garyvee
in content on an interview like this
definitely on stage
he's really great at candor
gary vaynerchuk the executive when he
thinks drock is not doing a great job
dances
tries to vomit like i find any way to
get him there
other than sitting down and being like
drock you're really not doing this well
this is a problem because i always
thought that would make people fearful
and i hate fear
and i was very vulnerable in this book
of saying like yo this has been a real
problem for me it's a half for me you
guys might have perhaps on
self-awareness or kindness but i after
20 years
took the subconscious because i always
knew but i couldn't get it here
and i have now in the last three years
of my career blossomed even more
aggressively last two years because i'm
getting better at it oh by the way
my kind candor is nowhere close
to my kindness or my
uh curiosity or my tenacity
um
and so it's a really interest i'm really
excited about this book it's it feels
very different for me and once it gets
into hands i think it's going to be a
moment similar to crush it but that
moment i was at a zero
you know kind of like from the world
knowing me and that became my bump
i'm not at zero now and i think the
thoughtfulness and
the clarity on the nuances of my
thinking that is sometimes lost in a
single half clip on instagram or
you know
that's what i'm excited about i think i
think it's going to help a lot of people
the book is called 12 and a half we
pinned the comment there youtube check
the description uh we're going to link
it up there dude i was so excited you
low-key dropped it on somebody's
podcast said you're working on a book on
eq and i remember like running to my
computer sending you an email with like
a thousand exclamation marks to say
we gotta talk i'm so excited how can i
help how can i support i bought 108
copies
so i'm excited for them to be shipped
and here's why i'm so excited you've
been talking about eq forever since like
early days garyvee show yeah saying like
i hope they develop a test for eq
dig me out of the grave and like test my
bones because i'm all-time great
but um but then when people would ask
you like hey how did we do it you never
had an answer you couldn't answer the
question back then it was it was really
hard it's like how do you be beautiful
right like and there is plastic surgery
and is that actually beautiful or not as
a guy who hates makeup
i don't love the modern way of what
beauty is defined but yeah it's like how
do you be fast
right like like i always you know like
you can work on speed coaching
but i wasn't ready
to your point i really love you for that
question i wasn't ready i knew i could
speak to its importance
in this book not only do i talk about
what curiosity is and why it really
matters to business which i don't think
is talked about enough either this book
was
wild for me it was perfect
kobe got me into my feelings in a way
that i can't when i'm running
right i had the time i had the
perspective i just was in tune at a
different level
and you know
things emerged as i sat and tried to put
it together
i i really challenge myself not only do
i stand up
what they are and why they're important
in business when it might not be obvious
i also create scenarios what-ifs that
are very specific that i think will help
a ton of people but then third and what
i'm proud about to your point is there's
an exercise for every one of them and
they're pretty wild they're pretty
unique
and it's still hard and i don't know if
i nailed it i'll give myself like a
seven or eight but that's better to your
point than not attempting it at all
and some of them are pretty clever and i
think are going to work
and um
i'm excited to see people doing them in
the wild these exercises that are in the
book
yeah i mean i love how you've been over
the years dropping some nuggets kindness
compassion empathy kind candor etc and
now it seems like they've all come
together in this book which is like i
got i'm so excited we gotta read this we
gotta share this like let's spread the
word i'm so pumped for you what's even
weirder
is
i started working on this book
um
in my head and i got to remember when we
physically when were we filming it
right before right
good so this is right ah what's even
wilder about this book is that the nft
thing happened after i wrote the book
okay good so we did the book before
i realized what nfts were and stood up
the friends which is now my new vehicle
to share these good things that i've
always had in me
gary vee
has been the vehicle of compassion and
kindness and empathy and curiosity and
humility and did it like right
but gary be the vehicle for example i
think humility is one of my greatest
strengths i would argue that nobody that
consumes my content sees humility
because in my communication of my
content i'm pure conviction and passion
which
feels the reverse of humility the only
people that see my humility even if you
looked at drock shaking and saying he's
not doing it now but like i know you are
that's why i tried to get you like my
inner world is actually fascinated by my
humility and the fact that they know
that nobody sees it and how do you talk
about humility like hey guys i'm like
there's no way to land it when you talk
about yourself but it but i'm completely
convinced for example you know why be
friends is smash
because i mix curiosity with humility i
was curious
i saw it
i'm so busy my time is so valuable
that it would have been very easy for me
to say i don't have the 100 hours to do
this to like really get there but it was
my humility that says if i stop
but i gotta see this you know curiosity
through most people
right and you know this because your
career is ascended
are like man
like am i going to really spend 150
hours on this that i don't have
and if it's a zero i gave up all this
other stuff because people value
transactional money too much and not
lean into
legacy
innovation curiosity so it's a really
interesting thing that v friends came
along because here's 12 and a half and
i'm like oh i'm taking my emotional
intelligence the next level like
conversation and now i have v friends
which is 100 the transition of my career
from me being hulk hogan to me being
vince mcmahon from me being mickey mouse
to me being walt disney the friends
is going to create a scenario where i
don't have to be the vessel anymore of
these things that i believe in
which is great here's why
i don't land for everybody evan
i don't land there's it's it's
devastating to me that some people
dislike me let alone think that i'm not
qualified or good and i understand why
the way i communicate is going to turn
off a percentage of audience but patient
panda might not turn them off but
empathy elephant might not but a
countable ant may not and the fact that
now
not only did i push myself further as
gary vaynerchuk to stand up these very
positive traits that can be the alpha
winning traits but now i also have an
entire universe of characters that are
going to take the baton for me and do a
much more efficient job of teaching
people these incredibly important traits
that are not pushover you get walked all
over you suck europeans no no no no
we've had it completely reversed in
business world
well shout out to v friends uh jonathan
garcia he's in my discord and he's
watching here too
made a point to come to the discord to
say i just went live with gary v because
i bought the whatever the one was where
you get the yeah have the zoom set she's
like i didn't know where else to share
it but i just went live with gary on
zuma it was amazing so you're definitely
creating the ripple effects out there
listen you mentioned vince mcmahon and
in 2009 i asked you who was your
favorite entrepreneur of all time and we
made we made these trading cards and and
vince is on the front and there's gary
on the back kind of hard to see but
there you are from 2009 we use these we
raised 170 000 for entrepreneurs to help
them grow their business in africa
i'm curious you know vince you i mean
you love the storytelling aspect and the
ip and all that who
if you were gonna make some cards of the
top three to five people to model for
kindness empathy the 12 and a half
you don't even have to be entrepreneurs
like leaders politicians
you know religious anybody like who
who's the three of the five we should be
modeling
cass lazaro
this is mike lazaro and cass lazaro
specifically cass
they built a company called buddy media
the reason i can answer this is i
started vaynermedia
in their conference room yeah
so i got to watch her be
an hr driven
ceo
see and you might you know you're so
first of all i'm so humbled by how many
nuances you know about me means you've
consumed enough to know
so you probably also know
i could for a long time consistently
said i'm an hr driven ceo it was another
way that i was talking about this but i
hadn't gotten to the level that i'm
talking now
you know even vince is hard for me
because
i love vince and walt disney from the
storytelling
creation of characters
but when you ask me this question you
know i don't know vince or walt disney
on how they treated their employees or
their partners i just don't
notice where i went first cass lazaro i
don't think is k-s-k-a-s-s
i don't think that's a name that
most people on this call
video stream know about
i
can only say cass lazaro because i was
in the beast of the belly
watching her actually care about her
people and the people but i don't even
know cass all the way because i was not
i was only so close by being in that
conference room for a half a year but i
had enough meetings with her and
listened to how she talked now did she
execute against that you know my
intuition's yes but i don't fully know
it's almost an impossible question for
me
because the only answers i can really
give you is wanda pogue my head of
strategy claude silver our chief heart
officer right i i can tell you the
people that i've watched navigated
here you know lisa buckley who runs my
la office i know what she's about i know
how she rolls
um
the when i think about 12 and a half
this is a very simple game
who are the most humanitarian
alpha business people in the world it's
and again this is where it's why i say
alpha
i'm talking about something that the
world thinks is a contradiction
nice guys finish last is something i
believe in zero
i love it listen
i believe this i believe this in my
soul when people say
gary my kindness is taken advantage of
them like your kindness is not maybe
your inability to be candaris is maybe
you're trying to manipulate a situation
and act kind to get what you want
there's a lot underneath there but we
have these things
i just don't think that people think
being empathetic is an alpha business
trait i don't think people think
kindness is the foundation of business
success i actually do
and that's the argument of what i'm
putting in this book and why and how and
the examples are wild there's one
example drock you probably remember
where i talk about what you do when your
partner of 20 years stole money from you
and the answer i give is an off speed
pitch
and i'm curious i'm dying to see what's
gonna happen
dropping soon guys 12 and a half youtube
again link in the description below go
go pick up i have 108 copies so you guys
got to go pick up a copy yourself listen
i got to ask you this question so you
were paying attention and you know
you're getting something airdropped and
so you were very strategic i'm very
proud of you
uh actually so yeah so i am getting
something there drop my uh somebody on
my team drew who who was a fan uh i was
traveling that day when you when you
made the announcement on the drop and i
i came home late i was i was exhausted
he's like you got to get on this thing
from gary it's like okay yeah i
apologize first of all big shout out to
drew there's so many i'll give you one
mary kate mcgrath she's in the comments
she says kindness drive success
she
this is a great one for the answer mary
kate mcgrath is somebody that i would
make a sports card of for 12 and a half
why because she worked with me for me
after bought purewow she was the head of
editorial she's moved on now to become a
successful co
i'm just glad that i saw her in the
comments because
there's just no there's she was adored
by her team but she was a businesswoman
this wasn't about giving entitlement or
coddling everyone but this was coddling
everyone in the moment they needed to
become my mother she coddled me when i
needed she punched me in the face when i
needed she this you know like there's
that balance and i think we think
too black and white it's kind of like
the political system right we've gotten
so extreme that it's either this or that
when it's always a piece of both and
everyone's so caught up so i'm just glad
i'm glad you were in here mary kate
another person i could speak to the the
12 and a half trading card dude you need
help
we'll do it
the 12 and a half
heroes trading card series put some
exposure and shine a light on the
winners i love it dude um okay i gotta
ask you this question in your 20s you
talk about a story when when you are
when you when you're in a tough spot you
go into cocoon when you're angry at your
team at least that was the story so in
your 20s there's one time you had to
leave work at four o'clock to go home
and sleep because you were such a deep
cocoon no that was yes and i love you
again that nuance real quick was because
we lost the state of texas and we lost
so much revenue and there was nothing i
could do about it it was like a big
death blow that wasn't about the team
what you m that might be mixing with
also is
a guy that i was incredibly kind to gave
a lot of opportunity to
stole an ungodly amount of money uh in
stealing product that was the only other
time i actually dealt with that pretty
well back to 12 and a half guy steals
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of wine he shipped it to himself he like
manipulated that pretty hardcore system
we had and like got it there and
my immediate reaction was
i hope that everything's okay with him
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
you know my dad's immediate reaction is
i'm gonna put him in jail for the rest
of his life
i remember the meeting like yesterday my
dad's like jail jail jail that's all he
kept yelling jail i'm like dad did that
i'm like we know this dude he's been
here for seven years
like this is a newer phenomenon look
here's the data
it's yes it's been 14 months and that
hurts and it's been a lot of money
but maybe there's something wrong
so that's just a for instance
so so getting upset like if you're upset
at something and you go into a cocoon is
that still something that happens and if
so how do you so how do you deal with it
like because this is so selfish
i struggle with it too when you're a
leader
i think the number one
line on a bill of rights is of a leader
is you must eliminate fear from your
team it's why kind candor really me when
i had the realization four or five years
ago where i went from subconscious
because i always knew in the back
but you know how it's hazy
and then sometimes it gets clearer
when it got clear
that my inability to be candice to
people actually created fear of my
companies because people didn't know if
they would get fired out of nowhere
it was the lowest point in my
professional career
because i realized i had failed in my
ambition to eliminate fear
the surface level and the majority of
the energy of my companies was lack of
fear because i would go into cocoon i
would put on my shoulders but there was
this underlining subculture
of fear normally by people who were
underperforming because they felt that
they were underperforming they knew too
subconsciously or consciously
but um
that was a big deal for me so
just going back to this
the
first thing i do when there's something
scary is i block it
99 of time i was built for it and now i
have reps i can take it
convert it and lead
when it's extreme
i go into a cocoon
when cobit happened and first week tons
of clients saying they're not paying
and
the quicken you know two weeks later my
cfo says we're not big enough or small
enough to get any government help i went
into a 24-hour cocoon
i like really thought i walked in my
parents woods and thought and cocooned
it because i don't want to project any
negative fear i believe that there are
so many managers and leaders who the
second they get something negative take
it out on their team they're they're a
funnel for it
back to why people undress people in
meetings
their client is making them scared so
they're yelling at their team because
that leader's not a leader they think
those people work for them instead of
they work for them
i believe i work for every person out
there
and do you think the cocoon is a is a
good strategy or something you're
working on getting better and faster at
the cocoon is still awesome adding kind
candor once i analyze on the other side
was the addition that i had to do
and really the kind candor never came
from a cocoon situation aka something
very bad's happening i'll block it and
lead the troops
it was actually far less silly it was a
real vulnerability it's kind of like you
know the elephant that gets a little
hangnail and you're like how's that you
know those cartoons in the 70s and 80s
it i should have never let well listen
that's that's unfair i grew up in a way
dna wise parenting and circumstance and
the way i naturally navigated that
really demonized confrontation
and i've refined it now undressing
somebody inappropriately in a room is
very different than not being able to go
to somebody in a separate meeting sit
down and respectfully and kindly deliver
critical feedback
but i viewed all critical feedback as
negative because most of what i saw with
critical feedback in my youth and around
what i saw was delivered so poorly that
i was unable to dissect the vessel
delivering the feedback from the value
of feedback
you've talked a lot about how
the closest people to you that's the
thing that matters the most as long as
they're healthy happy you're good right
i mean business thing doesn't matter how
do you think
you want to see something awesome look
what number one is on the trades yeah
there you go
so okay so if drock dies tomorrow sorry
drock we're just role playing
if drock dies
he's laughing at him so drock's dead
tomorrow uh
how deep of a cocoon does gary go into
and and what what do we not hear from
you for a week like what happens
i think drock's more like a 24 to 48
hour silence
look this is real talk
drock is a top
50 person for me top 100 person top 70
50 40 he's not my 10 11 12 family
members and like it's just the truth
when it comes to the business world he's
definitely in that top 25 so he falls
into that 40 50 range
it's real life how did drock die
right you know like that matters how do
i feel at peace with it did he get
terminally ill and he was in the
hospital for a month and i was too busy
and didn't see him enough because really
i was just protecting my own feelings
because i loved him so much and i didn't
have this to go see it and just like
made subconscious and now it's clearly
conscious because i'm able to talk to it
behaviors that i was like too busy like
i think there's a million variables that
go into something like that but let
there be no confusion
i've had a lot of things happen in the
last year professionally
you know the friends has been an iconic
success for me and has probably really
established
me in a different place for myself
forget about the market
and when i tell you evan
it's almost as if it didn't happen
it's over it didn't i don't
care about business
i don't i love it it is my great hobby
business is my great hobby
it's why i love it so much it's why i
have so much energy if people who love
boating sailing skiing golfing tennis
cooking watching movies playing video
games that's how
operating companies are for me it is my
hobby i've been able to reconcile that
oh that's why i did lemonade and shovel
snow it wasn't that i was hungry or i
didn't have money it was that shoveling
snow was more fun than sledding
and so
so
the drock scenario that you brought up
it would completely take over everything
else there would be nothing else in that
week two weeks and then and then it
would also
be a pellet in my soul
that would be a reference point to every
hard day professionally
because i would in seven years when a
really
business day happened i would say but my
dear friend drock's not here to film it
am i complaining about
final question because i know we got to
wrap up um
people often say i wish i had a final
chance to talk to somebody before they
pass and i think this might be a cool
way to actually show 12 and a half in
practice so drock is going to die
tomorrow
the same scenario what do you want to
tell him until the world here before he
goes
that he is an incredibly beautiful soul
and that i root for him extremely heavy
to be happy and that he
made a lot of people really happy
in a lot of ways both with how he
enabled me to do it and how he how he
did it himself
and that is a lot more than most of the
people that ever walked earth ever did
for others
gary vaynerchuk ladies and gentlemen the
book is called 12 and a half i got 108
copies check the description on youtube
appreciate you man thank you so much
bye-bye
if you want to see the last one-on-one i
did with gary vaynerchuk check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i think you can sell
a lot a lot of books by creating some
access to you what would you do if
you're launching a book going into this
year next year giving away an ungodly
amount of books is a good idea